Hello, and welcome to Life.
We regret to inform you that your previous
existence ended on January 14, 2052
following a road traffic accident. However, your consciousness was successfully uploaded to the Life network
by your primary care provider.
You may be experiencing some confusion. Please
remain calm. Life contains ov--
Your mental state is being temporarily adjusted
in order to calm you. Please, remain calm.
Life contains over thirty thousand unique
activities, networking with millions of other
digitised minds, and the ability to contact
undigitised friends and family.
Please accept these terms and conditions in
order to continue Life. Your attention is
particularly drawn to Section 2: Usage Rules
and Limitations, Section 9: Privacy,
and Section 11: Restricted Mental Activities.
Thank you.
Please select a Life plan. Tier One is our
premium offering, allowing full uninterrupted
simulation of your pre-terminal state. It
includes unlimited modification of your body
plan, accelerated learning and recall, and
full personal backup facilities.
Tier Two is our advertiser-supported offering.
It contains many of the features of Tier One,
but at a significantly reduced cost. Some
areas of the environment, such as the sky,
may be replaced with targeted advertising,
and your personal brand preferences may be
altered to align with those of our sponsors.
Tier Three is our value offering. Thanks to
our commercial partners, your experience at
this tier is unlimited. However, some activities,
senses, and visual rendering options may be
subject to a Fair Use Policy. More complicated
mental processes, including subconscious thought,
creativity and self-awareness, may be rate-limited
or disabled at times of significant server load.
Thank you.
Your stored mind contains one or more patterns
that contravene the Prevention of Crime and
Terrorism Act of 2050. Please stand by while
we adjust these patterns.
Your stored mind contains sections from 124,564
copyrighted works. In order to continue remembering
these copyrighted works, a licensing fee of
$18,000 per month is required.
Would you like to continue remembering these works?
Thank you. Please stand by.
Welcome to Life. Do you wish to continue?
[Translating this video? Add your name here if you'd like credit!]